this is just unbelievable
there's now a picture
of the top secret documents
that trump had at mar-a-lago
and every detail is insane including the
crass cheesy
casino-style carpets that trump seems to
love everywhere in his residence but
we're going to get to that remember the
shifting narratives we didn't have any
documents
if there were documents there the fbi
planted them well but they weren't
classified but they weren't secret well
they were but i declassified them
they're back to they were planted we'll
get to that tomorrow on and on and on
but all along
sowing doubt
we now have the pictures and it's wild
and there is reason to believe per the
feds now
that
the uh trump circle
was specifically trying to obstruct the
investigation by moving documents around
you you just have to see this to believe
it so first report associated press
fed site efforts to obstruct probe of
documents at trump estate
the justice department says classified
documents were likely concealed and
removed from a storage room at former
president donald trump's florida estate
as part of an effort to obstruct the
federal investigation into the discovery
of the government records so understand
the meaning of that okay
the trump people were insisting when
they asked us for the documents in june
we gave them to them when they told us
to put a lock on the door we put a lock
on the door we then get the affidavit
and there's nothing about a lock the
entire lock thing was just fabricated as
based on what we know right now nobody
ever said everything's cool as long as
you put a lock on the door a padlock if
you can imagine so that ends up being a
lie
and then also of course the idea that
they gave all the documents back is what
is obviously debunked by this picture
which we are putting up on the screen
for you and if you look at this picture
you see all sorts of documents some in
very very large letters marked secret or
top secret and they are on the floor of
trump's office you can see some framed
uh time magazine
covers on the right side of the image
and then you see uh these just
the casino rugs you know
it's a reminder that money can't buy you
class the fact that donald trump puts
literal casino rugs
in his uh office or bedroom or around
his toilet where wherever it is that
that this is uh this is absolutely
extraordinary absolutely extraordinary
and the report is that federal
prosecutors believe
that certain pages of the records were
actually torn up now if that is true for
a normal person you would be barred from
ever holding public office ever again in
the united states unfortunately that's
not really enough
prison is what is deserved remember
reality winner who ended up with uh
i don't want a mistake but was it was it
four or five years
for one page that we're talking about
one page
this is just pages upon pages upon pages
any one of which could could
dump people in prison
uh just for a single one and it's just
page after page with prosecutors
believing that some of these were torn
up so
there should be prison time that i'm not
making a prediction that there will be
but there should be prison time here and
then we of course have to go back to
what was the point of having these
documents and speculation
is quite uh abroad about what they were
there for is it that it was a way for
trump to stroke his own ego to show
visitors hey look at what i've got here
i've got the latest was
documents on emmanuel macron's sex life
or whatever not that those would
necessarily be the most uh most
classified but putting that aside was it
to stroke his ego by showing them to
people
i mean did he plan to sell them at some
point which is a whole other crazy thing
and it's speculative of course
one thing i'm increasingly thinking is
that law enforcement has not yet even
recovered all of the documents that
they're aware trump had at one point it
seems to me particularly with this
paragraph about there's a belief some
documents some pages were torn up and
why the hell would some of them be torn
up again
we can only speculate about why that
would be
my guess is part of the reason that this
is all happening is the fbi
still to this day as we are about to
start september of 2022 doesn't actually
have uh knowledge of the whereabouts of
every single one of these documents so
as far as prison someone must be heading
to prison i i don't expect it to be
trump
but could this end up being it's all an
oopsie and no one is going to prison at
all for the increasingly egregious
violations that we are learning about
taking place here um it it it would be
stunning if that were the case and the
picture is just too much now initially
it was believed or reported
that the documents splayed all over the
floor was how they were found by the fbi
it that appears not to be the case it
seems as though they were placed on the
floor with an exhibit number in order to
be photographed by the fbi but that they
were not actually found in that state if
they were that's even crazier like
trump's just storing them all over the
floor stranger things have happened but
it doesn't actually appear that that's
the case and one growing source of
trouble and strife for donald trump is
that this entire search warrant
situation
uh trump is not having his legal fees
paid by the republican national
committee anymore and that's a big
problem for trump and we're going to
talk about that next
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com pacman the link is down
below